if you are unvaccinated you need to be
wearing a mask to protect yourself
and others around you and we need more
people to get vaccinated to stop this
pandemic so overall the cdc
recommendations haven't changed
there has been no decision to change our
mass guidelines if
any decisions about public health would
be driven by the cdc
but of course we are engaged with public
health experts and the cdc about
how to continue to attack the virus
well there is a resurgence that's clear
and now there are debates in different
states about mass mandates coming back
not coming back
what happens with the vaccine the
president this afternoon repeating what
he said at the town hall last night
about
the vaccine and going forward take a
listen
we have a pandemic among
the non-vast vaccinated
those who are not vaccinated if you are
vaccinated
you are safe if you are vaccinated you
have over a 98
chance of never catching the virus at
all if you catch it
you're likely to get overwhelming proof
so far
that you're not going to be hospitalized
you're not going to be sick you're going
to probably have no
signs that you had it well the cdc has
has new numbers out about about that and
this
these numbers actually from july 12 so
they're a little
old but they're breakthrough covet 19
cases
500 5189 americans have been
hospitalized from breakthrough cases
this means
you've had vaccinations and you still
got covered and they went to the
hospital 1063 americans have died from
breakthrough covert 19 case
75 of all those who were hospitalized or
died from a breakthrough case were age
65
years or older and this is the delta
variant that everybody's talking about
so with that let's bring in our panel
ben dominic publisher of the federalist
juan williams is a fox news analyst and
steve hayes editor of the dispatch
steve uh there is this debate and um
you know the president seems to be
indicating that the cdc is going to
change its guidelines soon
yeah he's indicated that and he's also
suggested that the cdc may allow
children under 12 to be
vaccinated which i think would be a
welcome development at this point look
but i think it's unfortunate that we're
having a debate about going back to
masks
for for a number of reasons primarily
because if you have a debate about going
back to mass
it suggests to people who are vaccine
hesitant that there's not
the kind of upside that we've been
promising all along
to getting vaccinated and i think that's
the kind of mixed messaging that we
don't want from
the white house having said that the
only reason we're having this debate
about potentially having to go back
to masks is because you have
irresponsible people who are pretending
that there's no difference between
vaccine between being vaccinated
and between being unvaccinated many of
those are
charlatans and hucksters on the right
who are
you know in just asking questions mode
pretending that
there's really not much to know about
being unvaccinated versus being
vaccinated
or that there's not real scientific
evidence that being vaccinated provides
an advantage a significant advantage to
surviving to to avoiding
getting infected in the first place into
surviving any coveted infection that you
have
uh about the masks and and the vaccines
peter ducey
had a little back and forth with jen
saki on this issue
i think a lot of people got the vaccine
because
they were hearing him say if you get the
vaccine you don't have to wear
masks anymore so and that continues to
be cdc guidance
and you can say that that's going to be
the guidance forever
i am not the cdc director i understand
but people don't care
who tells them to wear a mask they
should care if it's the white house
shouldn't they care if it's a doctor or
medical expert or a spokesperson i think
most americans actually do care
the government okay ben
well i think that first off there's no
basis to have
any kind of masking for young children
who are going back to school
uh which is obviously a major point of
contention that we see playing out
across the country and
has a major role related to these mass
mandates you could potentially see an
argument made that it would make
teachers more comfortable or something
like that but circling back to steve's
point
i'd like to see the evidence that the
driving element for people not getting
vaccinated
is as he says hucksters on the right i
don't really see that in fact i see
almost total unanimity on the right in
terms of people recommending that people
ought to be vaccinated certainly among
the political class
and if there are hucksters who are out
there who are saying these types of
things
i certainly don't think that they have
the kind of truck the kind of
pull in this country in order to have
this type of effect i think
the far more far more reasonable and
obviously i think
data supported approach is to say that
in every aspect of the promises related
to vaccination
we have seen the government pull the rug
out from underneath people
over and over again about whether they
would be going to be able to go back
to living a normal life and that instead
of having the ability to go back to that
they're being told once again
the of the potential of mandates
lockdowns demands on their children
uh you know prevention of being able to
uh go back to
living the way that they thought they
were going to be able to if you had a
significant portion of americans
vaccinated
that's a far bigger danger when it comes
to discouraging vaccination
than anything that i've heard from any
huckster all right quickly steve
let me can i can i clarify yeah can i
clarify so i didn't say that that was
the cause i said it was a problem it is
a problem
and if ben doesn't know where the
problem exists i suggest you pay more
attention
but clearly there are people
particularly on the right it's not
exclusively on the right side
particularly on the right a lot of times
who are who are actually making that
case
yeah if it look if you don't think that
it's a problem that people are
changing this there's no problem if you
don't think it's a problem that there
are people on the right who are
pretending
in in the manner of just asking
questions that there's no difference
between facts
between being vaccinated and
unvaccinated i do think you ought to pay
closer
i said it was a problem when kamala
harris said that there was questions
about vaccines
under donald trump and it's a problem
obviously of anybody questioning it i
don't see anybody of the stature
of kamala harris on the right today
saying that people ought not be
vaccinated all right juan's on this
panel too i can't wait till you guys get
back in studio
uh so that the whole box thing and the
brady bunch
thing goes goes by the wayside i want to
play the sound bite about kids masked in
schools ben mentioned did take a listen
the cdc is going to say that what you
should do is
everyone over the age of under the age
of 12
should probably be wearing a mask in
school that's probably what's going to
happen
i think it's a scary thought that the
president of the united states is making
a forecast about what the cdc is
probably going to do
for the federal government to make some
kind of
big decision for the whole nation is
wrong
the local school boards make those
decisions
what about that one
well it's unlikely that children under
12 are going to be vaccinated before
school gets started so they're looking
for
precautions to protect children i was
with the governor of maryland today
republican larry hogan you said he
doesn't know if they'll start doing that
before
you know next next year uh vaccinating
those kids
so the reality is that the best way to
protect the kids right now
is for everyone to get vaccinated if
everyone's vaccinated
then the kids are going to have almost
no exposure to the virus i mean
we have a solution that doesn't involve
anybody imposing anything on anyone just
saying you know what let's act in the
best interest of
our health our families and our children
in terms of getting the vaccination
you know there's no way for kids to get
it if everyone's vaccinated
that last word here
i just don't think that we can set this
kind of rules
at the federal level i think to the
point that the of the parent that you
were
quoting there these decisions ought to
be made as close as possible
to the localities to the people and to
the people who are facing these
challenges which are
widely different different across
america when it comes to the level of
challenge
and i think that we do need to keep in
mind parents ought to be able to direct
how their children live and how they are
treated that is not the role that the
government ought to supersede in any
respect all right steve
you want to agree with ben to wrap up
the panel no i think that's right i mean
as a general case
the principle of subsidiarity suggests
that people closest to this
decision should be making the decision i
think when you have overwhelming
evidence of the success of the vaccines
it's fine to ask legitimate questions
about the long-term implications
but it's it's best to follow the science
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else